oh this is a fun one so we've got a
question here to wrap things up from
81 nc 19. that's great so to help me
with
the name recognition if you could just
make it a
very easy alphanumeric code that would
be extremely helpful moving forward
so even on facebook go ahead and change
your facebook name make it an
alphanumeric code like that
so the question is what exercises
are overrated and should be eliminated
part two of the question which exercises
are
underrated and need more attention
overrated exercises oh
i'm gonna start with a spicy one if
you're not a power lifter i think bench
press is overrated
i think that the
the freedom of movement that you can get
from dumbbells
um is probably a better option
the biggest drawback to dumbbells is
it's probably not a great idea to
go for a one rep max dumbbell press but
unless you're a power lifter you don't
necessarily need to know your one rep
maxes in the first place but
yeah it's um like dumbbell bench is a
lot more joint friendly for a lot of
people because you can do it with
a a quasi neutral grip
um which which i have found helps a lot
of people who have either elbow or
shoulder issues
like i said you have more freedom over
the range of motion for most people it
the dumbbell press movement of your
hands
just feels more natural than your hands
being locked in a
a given position like x distance from
your shoulders
for for the entire press um
and you can also just pretty easily get
a longer range of motion
if you want for a lot of people that
doesn't matter but
especially for people with relatively
big chests
a bench press is like a partial range of
motion
exercise which is perfectly fine if
you're a power lifter and
minimizing range of motion helps you be
good at your sport but if you're
just training for general strength and
muscle development
it's probably not a great thing um so
yeah i think that uh
and i'm certainly not saying bench press
is a bad exercise
but the fact that it is like
the exercise that most people in the gym
care about
i think that again it's not bad but i i
i would say it is substantially
overrated
would it be controversial to suggest
that like essentially all calf training
is overrated
that is that's very controversial and
i'll fight you over that
calf training is the best
why do you say when's the last time you
trained cavs
two days ago really hell yeah i love
calf training dude i
i've taken months off of calf training
and i've not seen it
this is probably saying more about me
than calf training but
i have not seen any change in my calf
size
from like six months of d training well
i mean
if if we think about uh muscle
hypertrophy versus maintenance
we know that it takes way less stimulus
to maintain
adaptations than to accrue them in the
first place
and since you walk around day to day i
mean
your calves are probably getting
adequate stimulus to maintain whatever
muscle you built
so i i don't think not losing calf size
is evidence of calf training being
worthless i think that just shows that
walking around day-to-day is an adequate
level of stimulus to maintain whatever
you built
okay so build up some calf mass and then
it then it's useless then just walk
around all day
that's my modified hot take sure but
calf training is so fun
it's not fun it feels great are you
kidding me dude i have a
an e-version ankle sprain from my
wrestling days that
my ankle is still just a mess from it
your ankle fell
off yeah how are you doing that
uh i mean like you can't even move your
ankle how are you doing calf training
loading up a bunch of weight is the only
way that
that ankle can go into dorsiflexion and
so
i so i have really
[ __ ] up ankles for for anyone
listening
and i think the reason i like calf
training so much is
uh it's the only way that i can stretch
my
my calves and ankles out to make them
feel good
uh my body weight is insufficient
to to cause my body or to cause my
calves to go into
uh into dorsiflexion so getting on
something like a leg press
and loading up like four or 500 pounds
gives me enough force to actually go
into dorsiflexion and stretch my calves
out
man it feels good and just for context i
mean
your ankle your foot fell off you had a
basketball injury
yeah it it just everything broke and
tore
a bic a bystander vomited from seeing it
correct yeah i had a compound uh
tib fib fracture and when i stood up my
my foot was
pointed the wrong direction so yeah my
my left ankle is pretty pretty worthless
at this point
i will say for a less hot take
of overrated exercises i've gotten away
from doing the barbell military press
and i've moved more toward
unilateral dumbbell pressing overhead
almost like a circus dumbbell press
and i've found that it might be because
i have
one shoulder that's great and one that's
terrible but
the the unilateral approach to me feels
so much more natural
um you know i'm standing not against a
back pad so the scapula and the
glenohumeral joint can kind of move with
their natural
uh synchronicity between them um
i've got a lot of my clients switching
over from the traditional military press
to
to single single arm overhead pressing
how do you feel about that
no i could see that that uh that makes a
lot of sense
and a lot a lot of people that aren't
really into overhead pressing really
struggle with
clearing the chin and then kind of
getting back under the bar on the on the
military press yeah
yeah um any uh underrated exercises
so that we're not just completely
bashing things and being negative all
day
um
i think single leg rdls are great
um i was gonna say that god damn it okay
how about you i know i i have a
different one i have a different oh man
i was gonna say you can expand on that
and i'll come up with another one
uh yeah i think single leg rdls are
great i think they
um so
most the the vast majority of the people
who i have had try out single leg rdls
who come from any sort of strength
sports background um
primarily here i'm thinking mostly
powerlifting and a few weight lifters
so our sports are very bilateral uh
like squatting is a bilateral exercise
deadlifting is a bilateral exercise
there's some level of of asymmetry if
you do
like a split jerk but you know for the
most part
cleans snatches bilateral exercise
and i think that a lot of people wind up
with like the hip extensors on one
leg being considerably stronger than the
other
and the range of motion in their hips
differing a pretty fair amount and here
i'm thinking like uh adduction
and an internal rotation range of motion
and so a lot of times when people try
single leg rdls for the first time
they'll notice that the movement feels
pretty easy
on one leg they can you know
whatever implement they're lifting they
can take it all the way down to the
floor without much of an issue
control is good they get onto the other
leg and just balancing on that leg feels
fine but then once they get into
i don't know maybe 40 degrees of hip
flexion
then it just all starts falling apart
and the range of motion is way worse the
control is way worse
um strength through like the upper part
of the range of motion is pretty good
but once they start getting into deeper
hip flexion
one hip is way weaker than the other uh
and so i think single leg rdls one
are a good exercise to
like equally strengthen your hip
extensors on both sides
like i think that you get a good
training effect from it
and i think it's a good exercise for
shining a magnifying glass
on strength imbalances you may have
to be clear i'm not saying that in a
context of
oh if you're you know three percent
asymmetrical
you're going to get injured because i i
think that's how a lot of people think
about asymmetries
i'm i only worry about asymmetry insofar
as
if you have a major strength deficit or
a major movement deficit on one side of
your body
that could be negatively affecting your
performance so i'm thinking about this
purely from a performance perspective
not like a
injury perspective um but yeah i think
that
both as an exercise for actually
training your hip expenses and as
kind of a diagnostic tool single leg
rdls are absolutely fantastic
yeah i've been doing a ton of those
lately um i've been doing with it with a
dumbbell or a kettlebell
um i haven't gotten into the barbell too
much with those but
that'll be down the road once i get a
little more comfort with it
my underrated exercise is for the
physique oriented folks out there
when you think of lat development you
know everybody's doing a million kinds
of rows a million
kinds of pull-downs and pull-ups the
straight arm pull-down
i think is a very underrated exercise
for lat development
and if you're fortunate enough there's
the old-school
hammer strength pullover machine oh hell
yeah that is only found in like the
dungeon gyms and then just like you
you'll
bump into it randomly and you'll be like
how did this get here
but that machine is so clutch
it should be mandatory in all commercial
gyms
so clutch for lat development absolutely
love it
you it is an ungodly lat pump that
cannot be replicated
no i agree i i've i don't think i've
ever used the original machine but i've
used
that type of machine in
one of the gyms that i used to train at
maybe five years ago had that machine
and yeah like i i do very little
direct lat training but that machine
just felt so good
i still found a way to use it like two
or three times a week